[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
morgen soll bekannt werden wie hoch die
gasumlage ausfällt die ab Oktober
erhoben wird also wie viel Cent pro
Kilowattstunde danach kann man sich dann
grob ausrechnen was an Mehrkosten auf
einen zukommt bei unverändertem
Verbrauch heißt also Heizung runter
drehen oder deutlich mehr zahlen nun ist
es steuertechnisch so dass auf diese
Umlage auch noch Mehrwertsteuer anfällt
das will die Bundesregierung eigentlich
nicht da sind sich alle drei
Koalitionäre einig aber im gemeinsamen
europäischen Binnenmarkt können
Mitgliedstaaten nicht einfach so die
Mehrwertsteuer wegfallen lassen also hat
der Finanzminister jetzt einen bit-brief
nach Brüssel geschrieben zu diesem und
zu anderen Themen äußerte er sich heute
im ZDF sommerinterview Christiane
hübscher Bericht
Christian Lindner erarbeitet sich gerade
einen Ruf als nein sage als er diese
Woche nein sagt zu einem Nachfolger für
das 9-euro-ticket da spricht er von
gratis Mentalität das stößt vielen auf
bedauern aber tut Lindner seine Wortwahl
nicht ich gehöre zu denen die klar
ansprechen was ist und ein kostenfreier
nahezu kostenfreier öffentlicher
Personennahverkehr das ist nichts was
wir auf Dauer leisten können
irgendjemand muss das ja bezahlen
finanzielle Zumutungen überall morgen
kommt mit der Verkündung der gasumlage
die nächste für viele Bürger das darauf
aber auch noch Mehrwertsteuer gezahlt
wird das will der Finanzminister noch
verhindern ich habe nach Brüssel
geschrieben und setze mich dafür ein
dass abzuwenden nehmen Sie für heute
einfach am Tag bevor die Umlage kommt
dem politischen Willen der
Bundesregierung dass wir nicht von der
Mehrwertsteuer profitieren wollen warum
dann nicht auch die Energiekonzerne die
an der Krise verdienen mit einer
übergewinnsteuer belegen RWE zum
Beispiel hat dem ersten Halbjahr im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr seinen Gewinn
mehr als verdoppelt Christian Lindner
aber sagt mal wieder nein wir würden
unser Steuersystem der Willkür
ausliefern alle die sich damit in meinem
Ministerium beschäftigen warnen davor
und deshalb sage ich in Deutschland sind
Gewinne bereits sehr hoch besteuert
Widerrede kommt vom grünen
Wirtschaftsminister da ist Geld und zwar
Geld mit dem die Konzerne oder Betreiber
von Energieanlagen selbst nicht
gerechnet haben da sollte doch einen
Teil dazu dienen können Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher zu entlasten immer
öfter zeigt sich so wie unterschiedlich
die Regierungsparteien in der Krise
ticken und Lindner muss eingestehen die
FDP leidet an der Ampel immer wieder
Forderungen von SPD und Grünen den
Koalitionsvertrag neu zu verhandeln und
die Linie der Politik weiter nach links
zu verschieben das ist für die FDP und
unsere Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer eine große Herausforderung
und deshalb haben wir sicherlich einige
Wählerinnen und Wähler der
Bundestagswahl die momentan einem
kritischen Auge auf uns schauen mehrere
Landtagswahlen gingen zuletzt verloren
in den bundesweiten Umfragen fallen die
Liberalen auf aktuell sieben Prozent der
Parteichef selbst sorgt für negativ
Schlagzeilen zuletzt aus dem
Autoliebhaber eine zu große Nähe zum
Porsche-Chef nachgesagt wird Lindner
aber verteidigt diese Kontakte im ZDF
sommerinterview okay dass die Politik
auch die Bundesregierung keinen Kontakt
mit der Wirtschaft pflegt ich betrachte
das jedenfalls als meine Verantwortung
niemand fordert in der Debatte dass er
keinen Kontakt zu
wirtschaftsvertreterinnen haben soll
aber er hat privilegierten Zugang eine
ganz besondere Nähe zur Autolobby und
Herr Lindner hat mich heute im Interview
nicht davon überzeugt dass das anders
ist
Bundesfinanzminister das war immer
Lindners Traumjob er nehme in Kauf dass
es auf und abgehe sagt er heute
ein Jahr ist es sehr dass die westlichen
Verbündeten Hals über Kopf aus Kabul
abzogen 20 Jahre Einsatz in diesem Land
und dann ein solch unrühmliches Ende ein
Jahr sind auch die Taliban und wieder an
der Macht und es kam so schlimm wie
befürchtet in jeder Hinsicht
wirtschaftlich ist Afghanistan im freien
Fall und von Frauenrechten ist nicht
mehr viel übrig
in Kabul haben einige Frauen gestern
noch mal versucht zu protestieren ihr
Recht auf Arbeit und Freiheit gefordert
doch die Taliban haben das brachial
beendet
die neuen alten Herren an der Macht
haben das Rad der Zeit umgehend
zurückgedreht Kathrin Eigendorf und
Sebastian ehm waren für uns in
Afghanistan ein geheimer Ort irgendwo in
Afghanistan die Mädchen die das Gebäude
verlassen haben es eilig sie sind
Schülerinnen in einer untergrundschule
ihre Lehrerin verabschiedet sie am Tor
und mahnt sie zur Vorsicht denn sollten
Sie entdeckt werden würden die Taliban
die Schule sofort schließen auch Layla
heidari Afghanistans bekannte Frauen und
Menschenrechtsaktivistin arbeitet jetzt
im Untergrund in ihrer geheimen
Werkstatt in Kabul treffen wir sie
Afghanistan ist kein Platz mehr für
Frauen wir sind alle in diesem
Massengrab begraben es gibt kein Glück
keine Hoffnung nichts mehr für uns in
ihrer Werkstatt bildet sie mehr als 30
Frauen aus als Schneiderinnen und
Juweliere das soll ihnen irgendwann das
Überleben sichern leider heidari wurde
selbst als Zwölfjährige verheiratet ließ
sich später mit 21 scheiden ein harter
Kampf um Freiheit liegt hinter ihr trotz
aller Gefahren und Schwierigkeiten will
sie in Afghanistan bleiben
welche Rolle Frauen in den Augen der
Taliban spielen erlebe ich selbst der
Sprecher der Regierung möchte beim
Interview nicht mit mir zusammen im Bild
zu sehen sein ich habe keine Probleme
mit der Anwesenheit dieser Dame wie
respektieren sie ich habe auch keine
Probleme mit ihren Fragen meine einzige
Bitte ist uns nicht im gleichen Bild zu
zeigen
ich bin die Journalistin sie können
nicht nur mit der Kamera sprechen sie
müssen mit mir reden wenn nicht gehen
wir erkläre ich dem Sprecher nach einer
langen Debatte einigen wir uns dass er
nicht neben mir im Bild zu sehen sein
wird
wo steht im Koran das Mädchen nach der
sechsten Klasse keine Schule mehr
besuchen dürfen wir bestreiten die
Anschuldigungen dass Frauen hier keine
Rechte genießen unsere Regierung ist
eine islamische und unter ihrer
Herrschaft sind die Rechte aller Bürger
gesichert
die SchülerInnen der untergrundschule
die sich weiterhin heimlich treffen
sehen das anders Tränen fließen während
wir den Unterricht Filmen eine ganze
Generation von Afghanen fühlt sich um
ihre Zukunft betrogen
Sakina die Lehrerin ist selbst erst 17
und musste die Schule verlassen ihr
Traum war es Architektin zu werden nun
unterrichtet sie Englisch
die Situation ist so schwierig für uns
aber ich werde nie aufgeben ich werde
weiter lernen und unterrichten
dass sie ihren Unterricht weiter
finanzieren kann und dass ihre Schule
nicht entdeckt wird das ist für Sakina
und ihre Schülerinnen jetzt die größte
Hoffnung
und darüber wollen wir mit einer Frau
sprechen die sich in Afghanistan sehr
gut auskennt mit mit Shiki bababori sie
ist Ethnologin und Journalistin hat als
Reporterin immer wieder aus Afghanistan
berichtet und ist im Alter von 13 Jahren
aus diesem Land auch nach Deutschland
gekommen Frau Barbari guten Abend nach
Köln hallo schönen guten Abend sie haben
ein Buch geschrieben mit dem
bezeichnenden Titel Afghanen
Spielball der Politik daran kann man
denken wenn man sich anschaut wie eilig
die Taliban es hatten die Rechte der
Frauen wieder zu beschneiden
ja unbedingt das hat ja keine Wochen
oder wenige Monaten gedauert bis die
dann auch das Ministerium für Frauen an
Ministerium für Tugend und Laster
umgenannt haben und Tag für Tag seither
die Richter der Frauen mehr einschneiden
es gab ja jetzt auch noch mal
Demonstrationen aber das sind wohl nur
noch wenige die sich das trauen oder wie
schätzen Sie das ein ja unbedingt das
hat sie ja im letzten Jahr hat es sehr
prompt nach der über machtübergreifung
der Taliban Demonstrationen seitens der
Frauen gegeben die dann sehr brutal
niedergeschlagen worden sind und dann
nahmen die sehr ab weil an wirklich
einfach der der Umgang mit diesen Frauen
sehr brutal und sehr schlimm war aber
jetzt wegen auf wegen einem Jahr Abzug
der NATO und der machtübergreifung der
Taliban sind Frauen wieder auf die
Straßen gegangen gestern vor allem waren
wieder welche zu sehen die rausgegangen
sind die nach ihren Rechten und vor
allem sie rufen und skandieren dass sie
Arbeit Brot und Möglichkeit wollen
einfach weil die Arbeitslosigkeit zu
hoch ist und die Situation heißt auch
deswegen sehr schlimm im Land Bilder
davon vorhin schon gesehen sie waren ja
oft in Afghanistan also in ihrem
Geburtsland um dort bei der
JournalistInnen Ausbildung zu helfen
also junge Afghaninnen beizubringen wie
wir hierzulande Journalismus machen
haben sie da jetzt zu diesen Frauen
eigentlich noch Kontakt was was hören
sie ja auf jeden Fall also diese
Standards dass das Journalismus dort den
jungen KollegInnen beizubringen
nahezubringen
waren sehr große Erfolg was die Deutsche
Welle Akademie ja auch über viele Jahre
gemacht hat und jetzt einfach auch wegen
der Sicherheitssituation dort nicht zu
realisieren ist ich habe zu einigen
wenigen inzwischen dort Kontakt viele
sind oder hatten die Möglichkeit über
die in kanadische Botschaft oder
französische Botschaft oder auch die
Deutschen die Reporter ohne Grenze haben
einige aus dem Land bringen können aber
natürlich nicht alle einige die obwohl
sie auf diese evakuierungslisten drauf
sind sind noch diesem Land und fürchten
natürlich dass sie entdeckt werden dass
es rauskommt dass sie als
JournalistInnen im Land gearbeitet haben
was schlimmer Folgen für sie hätte und
für manchen hört man wahrscheinlich gar
nichts mehr oder genau das ist auch
etwas was wobei ich dann natürlich
überhaupt nicht einzieht einschätzen
kann ob sie jetzt untergetaucht sind
einfach ob sie an aus Angst oder ob
ihnen was passiert ist also das ist
schon ein sehr komisches Gefühl wenn ich
jetzt mal jenseits der der
frauenthematik auf die Art und Weise
gucken wie die Taliban regieren einem
Vorwurf der der alten Regierung der vom
Westen gestützten Regierung hier immer
gemacht wurde war dass sie so unfassbar
korrupt war und das hat ja auch
Sympathie gekostet und manche haben
sogar auf die Taliban vielleicht sogar
gehofft dass es dann besser wird was
hören Sie dazu und wie schätzen Sie das
ein ja auf jeden Fall durch das ganze
Geld was habe Garnis dann geflossen ist
in den letzten 20 Jahren ist auch die
Korruption sehr nach oben geschalten
geschnallt und das hat viele Leute sehr
verzweifelt gemacht weil alles war ging
nicht ohne dass man jemanden schmieren
wusste ob jetzt ein Kind anzuschulen war
oder ob jemand irgendwie versetzt worden
ist alles musste bezahlt werden und die
Taliban haben auch damit sehr viel
gespielt und haben sehr zu in Aussicht
gestellt dass das aufhören würde wenn
sie an der Macht sind oder wenn die
Amerikaner oder der besten Abzüge und
jetzt sind sie aber so langsam in den
Institutionen wo sie das Sagen haben wo
sie quasi in dem Geschmack kommen wie
das ist mit Geldern oder mit dieser
Macht da umzugehen und verhalten sich
genau gleich ja das ist ja ein bekanntes
Phänomen wenn die Honigtöpfe sich dann
öffnen dann werden die anderen auch
nicht besser manche hoffen zumindestens
oder von manchen Afghanen hört man dann
auch in Berichten die Aussage seit
zumindest jetzt etwas sicherer geworden
liegt das nur daran dass die Taliban auf
sich selbst jetzt keine Anschläge
verüben naja ich meine mit dieser
Sicherheit das ist so eine Sache das ist
also das betrifft definitiv nicht die
Situation der Frauen weil die sie dürfen
einfach nicht möglichst das Haus
verlassen sie dürfen nicht reißen ohne
männliche Begleitung und sie dürfen
nicht zur Schule gehen also die Mädchen
oder die Mütter ihre Mütter nicht zu
Arbeit gehen also das betrifft diese
Sicherheit betrifft jetzt und auf gar
keinen Fall die und auch nicht die
Menschen die in Afghanistan in den
letzten 20 Jahren dazu beigetragen haben
dass es so einigermaßen so eine
Zivilgesellschaft im im Begriff war
zumindest dass es aufgebaut wird die
sind definitiv in Italien da Taliban
ausgesetzt es gibt heutzutage auch in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten hat es
immer wieder Anschläge im Land gegeben
allerdings nicht seitens der Taliban
sondern der is also die Rollen haben
sich einfach im Moment etwas verändert
dass die Taliban jetzt quasi so eine die
Rolle haben der der was die ehemalige
afghanische Regierung hatte und die is
die Rolle der Taliban einnimmt und ihnen
auch dann vorwirft mit dem Westen
zusammenzuarbeiten weil sie halt dann
den Konferenzen teilgenommen haben
vielen Dank für das Gespräch sehr gerne
mehr zur Lage auf Afghanistan finden Sie
bei uns online auf ZDF heute auch zu den
untergrundschulen in denen jetzt im
Kabul heimlich unterrichtet wird
und wir schauen wieder nach Deutschland
das Thema Gasversorgung hatten wir ja am
Anfang der Sendung schon und dazu gab es
heute noch weitere Meldungen Heinz ja
der Füllstand der deutschen Gasspeicher
hat jetzt schon die Marke von 75%
überschritten damit wurde das erste
Zwischenziel zwei Wochen früher erreicht
als nach einer neuen Verordnung
vorgeschrieben Anfang Oktober sollen es
mindestens fünfundachtzig Prozent und am
1 November mindestens 95% sein um gegen
einen möglichen Totalausfall russischer
Lieferungen besser gewappnet zu sein und
ebenfalls zur Absicherung der Versorgung
sollen energietransporte wie etwa Kohle
Öl und Gas auf der Schiene Vorrang
bekommen das sieht eine Verordnung des
Wirtschafts und des Verkehrsministeriums
vor die derzeit in der Regierung
abgestimmt wird das soll gewährleisten
dass etwa Kohlekraftwerke und
Raffinerien ausreichend versorgt werden
bei einem Brand in einer koptischen
Kirche im Großraum von Kairo sind
mindestens 41 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen unter den Todesopfern sollen
Kinder und der Priester der Kirche sein
das Feuer brach offenbar zu Beginn des
Gottesdienstes aus unter den Gläubigen
kam es zu einer Massenpanik Auslöser des
Feuers soll eine defekte Klimaanlage
gewesen sein
im Zusammenhang mit dem rätselhaften
Fischsterben in der oder haben sich am
Abend den Stettin die
umweltministerinnen aus Polen und
Deutschland getroffen
Bundesministerin Lemke sagte
anschließend man habe gemeinsame
Schritte beschlossen und wolle die
informationsketten verbessern seit Tagen
sammeln Helfer entlang der Oder
massenhaft verendete Tiere ein für
morgen werden weitere Laborergebnisse in
Brandenburg erwartet solange die Ursache
unklar ist sind auch flussabwärts im
Stettiner Haff angeln und baden verboten
in diesem Jahr sind in Europa bisher
6.600 Quadratkilometern Land verbrannt
seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen ein
Höchstwert so der Koordinator des
europäischen
waldbrandinformationssystems und wir
befinden uns gerade erst in der Mitte
der brandsaison die Situation sei
beunruhigend Trockenheit und extrem hohe
Temperaturen hätten ganz Europa erfasst
so seien dieses Mal nicht nur wie sonst
üblich hauptsächlich die
Mittelmeerländer betroffen sondern auch
Länder wie Rumänien oder Slowenien das
ist eine schlimmsten Brände seit
Generationen erlebt habe
wer derzeit baut umbaut oder saniert
macht frei um die Erfahrung das kann
sich ziehen und waren Baustellen
natürlich noch nie Orte an denen immer
alles nach Plan läuft das ist länger
dauert und am Ende mehr kostet als
ursprünglich gehofft das ist nicht neu
aber wie sich das in der Branche
inzwischen entwickelt hat ist schon
heftig nicht nur dass es zur
Geduldsprobe wird Handwerker zu bekommen
oder Material zu bestellen die Baukosten
sind insgesamt Stall nach oben
geschnellt und das hat natürlich folgen
es wird mittlerweile weniger gebaut es
geschieht also genau das Gegenteil von
dem was die Bundesregierung und ihre
bauministerin bei Amtsantritt
versprochen haben Andrea Maurer
berichtet
hier im Zementwerk Lengfurt kann die
bundesbauministerin sehen vor welchen
Herausforderungen das Bauen steht zement
ist der Klimakiller der Baubranche ohne
Zement aber geht es nicht eine ganze
Industrie muss sich neu aufstellen
grüner werden es wird eine Baustelle
auch ihrer Amtszeit sein die mit einem
großen Versprechen verbunden ist 400.000
neue Wohnungen pro Jahr wir werden diese
Wohnungen brauchen deswegen ist es ja
keine Möglichkeit zu sagen dann bauen
wir mit Blick auf den Klima nicht
sondern wir müssen anders bauen Klara
Geiwitz ist eigentlich keine die mehr
verspricht als sie halten kann
pragmatisch faktenorientiert und doch
ist sie nun Ministerin eines der größten
versprechen dieser Regierung es ist auch
ein wahlversprechendes Kanzlers als
dessen vertraute sie gilt mit dem sie
2019 für den SPD-Vorsitz kandidierte und
unterlag dieses Versprechen da hat man
sehr schön reingeritten würde ich mal
sagen von den Kollegen her es wissen
alle sagen auch alle unter der Hand auch
die Kollegen der Ampelkoalition die
400.000 Wohnungen sind so nicht zu
realisieren die Situation war so im
letzten Jahr das sogar weniger Wohnung
fertig geworden sind als mehr das heißt
es fehlen über 100.000 an diesem Ziel
und es wird auch so sein dass in den
nächsten Jahren das Ziel nicht erreicht
werden wird weil einfach die
Umweltsituation schlecht ist Zinsen
Material
Ressource Mensch fehlt auch und
Förderung
der ukrainekrieg hat die Situation
nochmal verschlechtert warum also hält
Klara Geiwitz an dem Versprechen fest
dadurch dass ich mich verabschieden
würde würde aber die Notwendigkeit nicht
weggehen dass wir mehr Wohnungen
brauchen das heißt wir müssen Druck
machen wir müssen sagen es ist
schwieriger geworden deswegen müssen wir
uns mehr anstrengen besucht bei einem
Wärmepumpenhersteller in Bayern
wärmewende im Gebäudesektor auch hier
hat galwitz hat die Regierung ein
förderversprechen gegeben das
Bundesregierung ist ja dass wir 500.000
Wärmepumpen pro Jahr in Deutschland dann
auch bauen können allein es fehlen
Fachkräfte die Lieferzeiten sind lang
das Wirtschaftsministerium hat die
Förderung von Wärmepumpen Ende Juli
nochmal von bis zu 30.000 auf bis zu
24.000 Euro gesenkt Habeck setzt voll
auf Sanierung im Bestand die
energetische Neubauförderung hat er an
die bauministerin abgegeben es ist wohl
nur ein scheinsieg für galwitz bei der
Mittelverteilung ist es in der Tat so
dass die Mittel im Prinzip fast alle im
Hause Harbig geblieben sind für die
bestandsförderung und für das Thema für
das wichtige Thema
bezahlbarer Neubau ist so gut wie gar
nichts im Moment da eine Milliarde Euro
hat ja niemand verloren und wir sind ja
auch nicht beim Schlamm kämpfen sondern
das geht ja darum dass man sagt wo ist
es denn sinnvoll strukturell angesiedelt
und da ja Robert Habeck selten nach den
400.000 Wohnungen gefragt wird sondern
meisten ist es schon sehr sinnvoll dass
wir das dann auch verantworten es ist
ein Amt verbunden mit einem großen
Versprechen nicht wenige sagen
inzwischen eine politische Mission
Impossible
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Sport
an diesem Wochenende zuerst du
Fußball-Bundesliga da gab es heute zwei
Spiele bayern München hat 2:0 gegen den
VfL Wolfsburg gewonnen Mainz und Union
Berlin trennten sich torlos
unentschieden
bei den European Championships in
München weil es aus deutscher Sicht ein
Tag mit einer ganzen Reihe von Medaillen
erfolgen in Bronze Silber und auch
zweimal Gold und zwar im Turnen für
Elisabeth Seitz und immer Malewski
Mama
mahlowski mit gerade einmal 18 Jahren
zwei EM-Medaillen in München immer
Malewski wird zum Gesicht der deutschen
Ton Zukunft nach Bronze in der
Mannschaft bewies die Chemnitzerin auch
am Schwebebalken ihre Nervenstärke und
holte sich die em-krone ich habe keine
Worte dafür was heute passiert ist ich
freue mich so mega und mit dieser
Stimmung dass man einfach toll auch die
Stimmung bei Elisabeth Seitz großartig
nach ihrem Triumph von Stufenbarren
obwohl es keine perfekte Vorstellung der
deutschen rekordmeisterin war reichte es
für die 28-Jährige an ihrem
Lieblingsgerät zum ersten
internationalen Titel
und die European Championships morgen
live im ZDF zu sehen von 9 Uhr an bei
der schwimm-europameisterschaft in Rom
hat Isabel große über 200 Meter Freistil
Bronze gewonnen Gold ging an die
Niederländerin Maritz den Bergen zweite
wurde die Briten freier Anderson
Freistil Silber gab es für große bereits
über 800 Meter am Freitag und eine
dritte Medaille kann die 20-Jährige aus
Magdeburg dann am Mittwoch noch über die
400 Meter holen
es ist immer wieder erstaunlich was
Astronauten oben aus dem also alles
sehen können nicht nur Schönheit und
Verletzlichkeit unseres Planeten auch
Details so erzählt Matthias Maurer dass
er von der ISS aus beobachten konnte wie
der Krieg in der Ukraine begann die
einschlagenden Raketen waren als
Lichtblitze zu sehen
es muss eigentümlich gewesen sein in
einer solchen Situation mit den
russischen Kollegen zusammen in rund 400
Kilometer Höhe über die Erde zu fliegen
und gemeinsam zu sehen was für ein
Wahnsinn sich dort unten abspielt
insgesamt war Maurer ein halbes Jahr im
All in seiner Heimat im Saarland wurde
seine Rückkehr heute gefeiert Susanne
Freitag berichtet
[Musik]
der Astronaut gerührt 5000 Fans
begeistert
als hätte peter Schilling sein Lied für
diesen Tag geschrieben
als ich das Lied völlig losgelöst damals
gehört habe war es für mich noch
komplett unvorstellbar dass ich mal
selbst losgelöst von der Erde sein werde
damals wollte ich eigentlich nur Pilot
werden die Welt von oben zwei sehen aber
das ist so weit hinausgeht das war für
mich undenkbar und jetzt feiern sie ihn
wie einen Rockstar auf der Erde wo über
1.500 Menschen an seiner Mission
mitgearbeitet haben
ist eine Teamleistung auch wenn ich
jetzt deshalb feiert sein Team natürlich
auch mit
herzlich willkommen heute ist es gefüllt
natürlich auch mal so ein emotionaler
Höhepunkt so Party Matthias ist zurück
alles ist rund super gelaufen und das
muss jetzt auch ich sag mal in die
Gesellschaft reingebracht werden
Weltraum Begeisterung wecken so früh wie
möglich das gehört jetzt zu den Aufgaben
des Astronauten Botschafter sein für die
Raumfahrt auch bei politischen
Vertretern immer wieder sagen
Weltraumforschung sei teuer aber wichtig
zum Beispiel wenn es um den Klimawandel
geht ausgetrocknete sehen Waldbrände all
das hat er von oben sehen können es hat
mir gezeigt wie endlich dieser Planet
ist unendlich sind natürlich auch die
Ressourcen und zu sehen wie dieser
Planet jetzt gekocht wird hier in Europa
wie alles so trocken ist ist eine
wirklich sehr sichtbare sehr spürbare
Äußerung des Klimawandel während Maurers
Mission brach der Krieg in der Ukraine
aus zum ersten Mal wurde die Raumfahrt
zum politischen Spielball niemand dort
habe den Krieg gewollt sagt er während
Russland mit dem Ausstieg aus der ISS
droht
sie haben im letzten Jahr zwei Module
hochgeschickt zu iss die sind jetzt in
der Lage oben wissenschaftliche
Forschung zu machen für diese 20 Jahre
gearbeitet haben also es wäre eigentlich
in Schuss ins Knie für sich selbst wenn
sie jetzt aus dem Programm aussteigen
würden
Matthias Maurer macht jetzt noch ein
paar Monate Werbung danach wird der
aktiv an der Vorbereitung von
Mondmissionen mitarbeiten
der Mond ist so das große große Ziel was
jedem von uns da im Herzen brennt da
möchten wir hin und ja das ist steht bei
mir auch als Nummer eins auf meiner
Wunschliste für seine Fans aber ist und
bleibt er ihr Matthias egal ob sein
Fußabdruck irgendwann auf dem Mond zu
sehen sein wird oder nicht
und jetzt noch der sonntägliche Blick
auf die nächste Woche zumindest auf
Ereignisse die schon fest stehen
Christiane Hoffmann hat einige Termine
zusammengestellt angefangen mit der
vorhin schon thematisierten Gas Umlage
[Musik]
am Montag will das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium bekannt
geben wie hoch die gasumlage ausfällt
damit sollen alle Gaskunden an den
gestiegenen Kosten beteiligt werden
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck hatte eine
Spanne zwischen 1,5 und 5 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde angekündigt
am Mittwoch beginnt in Goslar der 60
deutsche Verkehrsgerichtstag bei dem
Treffen von rechtswissenschaftlern und
Experten für Verkehrssicherheit soll es
unter anderem um Cannabis im
Straßenverkehr und die Sicherheit von
Radfahren gehen in Brüssel beginnen am
Donnerstag Vermittlungsgespräche
zwischen Kosovo und Serbien der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell hat dazu
Kosovo Ministerpräsidenten Kurti und
Serbiens Präsident Vucic eingeladen
dabei geht es um ungeklärte Grenzfragen
und die Souveränität des Kosovo
Bundeskanzler Scholz soll am Freitag zum
zweiten Mal vor dem
cum-ex-untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg
Aussagen als Erster Bürgermeister dort
hat es sich Scholz mit den Chefs der
Warburg Bank getroffen als gegen sie
bereits wegen Steuerhinterziehung
ermittelt wurde der Vorwurf Scholz habe
mit dafür gesorgt dass die
banksteuerrückzahlungen nicht leisten
musste konnte bisher nicht nachgewiesen
werden
die Wetteraussichten zum Start in die
neue Woche morgen wechselt bewölkt dabei
vor allem im Norden Osten sowie im
Südwesten einige teils kräftige Schauer
und Gewitter Höchstwerte 24 bis 31 Grad
die weiteren Aussichten am Dienstag
meist freundlich am Mittwoch zunächst im
Westen am Donnerstag dann verbreitet
gewittrige Regen im Osten bis zu 34 Grad
heiß im besten allmählich etwas kühler
das war es von uns an diesem
Sonntagabend gleich geht's mit dem
sonntagskrimi weiter und um 0 Uhr gibt
es dann die nächste heute Express und
hier freuen sich morgen Bettina
Schausten und Gundula Gause auf sie auf
Wiedersehen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]